living your life based off how other
people think of you is the fastest way
to hating your life think about it
everybody's got an opinion on what you
should do with your life from the moment
you wake up before you've even gotten up
there's a whole bunch of people out
there who have an idea for what you
should do with your day whether it's
your friends or your family or your
co-workers or your boss or your team or
your employees or your customers
everybody's got an agenda for your time
and the first thing that most people do
is you wake up you pick up your phone
and you start reacting to other people's
emergencies you are thinking about
putting out some content or expressing
yourself in some way or getting a new
haircut or getting some fresh clothes
and the first thought that then comes to
mind is oh how am I going to be seen
what are people gonna think it's funny
we want to put out content the number of
people who message me and say hey Evan I
want to put out content I want to create
my own YouTube channel but I'm too
afraid I'm afraid that nobody's gonna
see it and I'm afraid that people will
see it and they will judge me think
about how crazy that is and so people
keep getting stuck in this Loop of just
constantly overthinking instead of
actually doing and it's a giant dilemma
it's a big problem because you know your
people
watch the top team with believe Nation
hey it's Nina Carmichael and we made
these videos probably because you're the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of much more and
you need that push faster around
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael and our take on his top
10 rules for Success enjoy
[Music]
if you know that you could be here if
you have dreams goals aspirations
desires to be up here right like does
that do you have goals for where you
want to take your life of course you do
for where you could be
and the path to get there is filled with
other people's opinions the the blocks
of why you can't take the next step is
because of how somebody might judge you
because you're not actually that afraid
of failing you're afraid of failing and
who will see you fail
right you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner what's
the difference other people will see you
so you're not that afraid of failure
you're afraid of failing and who's gonna
watch you who's gonna see you who did
you fail in front of looking around like
oh did they did anybody see me
that's the problem
and so if you know you're capable of
more and you're stuck down here and
that's the only difference
you have to have to have to have to have
to learn to start to break that pattern
the second that you start to feel
somebody else's Judgment of you and
that's the reason why you're not taking
your idea to the next level it's not a
good enough reason nope not anymore not
for you
let me share with you a couple tips of
how you can take that concept and make
it practical
number one trust your ideas
trust your ideas trust that they came to
you the intention is good right ask
yourself this idea that came to me is is
the is the intention good are you in a
positive place or negative place right
if you're if the intention is negative
uh I hate that person and I'm going to
screw them over and I'm upset at them
when I'm in I'm in jealousy or rage okay
don't don't trust that idea but the
ideas that are positive the idea is
where you're feeling good and bold and
powerful and confident like I've got
this great idea you get these ideas in
the shower you get these ideas when
you're on vacation you get these ideas
when you're outside walking in nature
those ideas trust those ideas trust that
they came to you for a reason stop
overthinking them stop over judging them
stop trying to figure out how it's going
to work out before you take some kind of
action trust the ideas period it came to
you you are a genius therefore it's a
great idea and start taking some kind of
action on it step number two
when you feel the burn of somebody's
opinion on you even even if you even
haven't done it yet you just feel the
potential burn of somebody's opinion on
it teach yourself to go do that thing
do that thing just because
even it has nothing to do with your
business or your goals just because
I remember I was walking down a street
and I was on my way to my dance studio
so I owned Toronto Dental so it's the
largest salsa dance school in Canada
and that's a 25 minute walk something
like that 20 25 minute walk and I had my
music on in my ears and I'm dancing on
these little side streets as I'm walking
there and then I get to the corner of
young and uh Shepherd which is a really
busy intersection in Toronto and all of
a sudden what happens is lots of people
right it's busy intersection and what I
noticed myself doing
was I I stopped dancing I went from like
big dancing on the street walking down
the street let's go let's go to
you know just like a head Bob
right just the head Bob and I caught it
I said wait what am I doing
I'm I'm not live my life I'm not having
the fun that I should be having I'm not
playing big because what because there's
some random people around me
and as soon as I caught that then I
started dancing bigger I said put the
music on loud or started dancing bigger
right there on the corner young and
Shepard and
you know what most people didn't even
care
well she was like wait whatever walk
they don't even look at you uh some
people look and maybe they think it's
the worst thing ever or maybe it
inspires them maybe they have a smile
and they go off and make somebody else's
day a little bit brighter maybe they
decide that they're gonna take some kind
of dance class or sign up for something
to change their life a little bit right
we always assume the negative but
there's also people who are going to be
helping and inspiring when you bring it
down to the the worst person
that I can't do this because
somebody May judge me and think
negatively of of me
then you never end up focusing on the
people who you can serve you can help
and go have a big impact on
so even though that had nothing to do
with my business I just caught myself
playing small and the scary part was I
had probably done that walk hundreds or
thousands of times
and I never caught it
now I caught it
all right so I think we play small by
default we're worried about other
people's opinions by default and as soon
as you catch it you want to teach
yourself to go do that thing because not
taking action and the reason being
somebody else's opinion is that that's
not a good enough reason it can't be not
anymore not if you want to go off and
accomplish your goals because on that
climb up there will be people who will
attack you
there just will be and it has nothing to
do with you
a lot of people are are in such a
Negative spot and they took their shot
on their dreams and now because it
didn't work for them now nobody around
them can have success
so step one is to trust your ideas right
it came to you you're a genius let's go
do something about it step two is to not
allow the opinions of somebody else be
the reason why you don't take any kind
of action
and then step three is to remind
yourself that hurt people hurt people
I don't think they're really negative
people toxic people I don't think it's a
big thing to anybody think humans by
default are good we are built to serve
we want to help so why would somebody
who's built to serve
do something negative tell you that you
suck leave a nasty comment on your video
because they're in pain
because they're struggling because they
hate their life think about you when
when you were in a lot of pain when
you've struggled in your life did you
show up as an amazing human for all the
people around you did you never go and
give somebody a snarky remark
right are you always proud of how you
showed up when you've been stressed out
when you haven't slept when you're
dealing with a really frustrating
problem right of course not you you've
had those moments too now doesn't mean
that you go to leave somebody a really
negative comment on their YouTube video
but you have reacted out of emotion and
you have not been proud of yourself I
have you have everybody has it's part of
the human condition now imagine if
somebody is constantly being beaten down
constantly hating their life don't even
see a path out
how much rage they have inside them what
are they likely to do we'll continue
that behavior just on a bigger scale
crying out for an attention because they
have no friends because they hate their
life and this is the only way that they
get any kind of significance
and what you can do is when you see
something like that
flip it to empathy instead of feeling
anger instead of feeling rage instead of
feeling your own insecurity remind
yourself that hurt people hurt people
why would this person come and leave
such a nasty comment for you
but they don't even know you because
you're dealing with their own struggles
because if the highlight of their day is
coming and leaving a negative comment on
your video how much does that say about
how much they hate their life
and when you can actually feel that
it removes The Sting from the words
maybe there's something valuable in in
the comment
but a lot of times it's just hidden the
hidden value is there but it's under a
lot of negativity maybe there is
actually something in your video or
whatever you create that could be
improved
just the way they delivered the feedback
was really really negative
right so it allows you to actually see
the feedback and see the person when you
can remove the sting of the words by
recognizing that these people hate their
life
you can help them feel better by keeping
doing your thing and making more content
whatever you want to do in life whatever
your big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations are
you have a picture may not be a super
clear picture but you have a picture of
where you want to go and that's Noble
and that's valuable and that's serving
and you're going to touch a lot of
people's lives along the way there but
only if you act only if you do something
those great ideas do nothing if they
just sit in your head because you're too
afraid to take action because somebody
might judge you
the minute you can stop living your life
based off the expectations and opinions
of other people
that's when everything changes and
that's when life starts to get really
really good rule number two be the
leader that you desire be the change you
want to see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
not as much as the government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're gonna make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough
right it's like have you had a hard time
managing yourself have you had a hard
time sticking to your routines and
keeping to your motivation and staying
strong and the things that you say
you're going to do like self-management
self-leadership is hard enough now we're
going to go off and lead other people as
well and where do we learn about
leadership we don't go to school for
this we don't have programs we don't
probably have great mentors to help us
if you had jobs in the past or maybe you
had a job right now you probably don't
have the greatest leaders around you
most people suck at it but it doesn't
have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Evan Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know I've
never seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have you ever heard the expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
yeah and hopefully that's our goal for
life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks
it's more that you know you don't have
the skill set we don't have the skill
sets at the beginning to know how to
even find the right person let alone
manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work or overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right sound familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing are you going
to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide that you know
what I'm just gonna do it on myself
right I know I can get it done I'm just
gonna do it all myself does that happen
to you
[Music]
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you don't have a big mission it's
just it's just you cool go for it but if
you've got a big mission then it needs
to be team and that becomes a skill set
that you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that
and it's surprising how often you can
find things that support them and
support you not all the time I remember
having one guy in my team who his dream
was to be a baker
like what
I don't have an interest in opening up a
bake shop right but ultimately you
should you should leave us and go do
your passion because because I can't
help you inside of this job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give them to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know he had to go and move on and was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills if they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that
some kind of program some project
something that can also bring value to
the company then let's do it because
when people are working on the things
that they feel like they're growing in
and they're learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody
like a normal human being and actually
have a little bit of care and compassion
and curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point to then be able to
say hey no I want I want this person to
have come out of my organization whether
that's in a month or year 10 years from
now a better human because they were
with us and it's totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people
I want to see them win and you're
responsible for making sure that they
get pushed outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
it's a huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need rule number
happy right now
it's probably because you're not growing
humans want to grow we want to learn we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when
we feel like we're learning and growing
and the work that we do matters we feel
great right if you feel great when you
learn the new skill when you when you
help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it
felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row
where you feel like it's too hard it's
too big you're not growing you're not
learning there's
there's no hope
that leads down I really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be
and part of why we become entrepreneurs
is because we want to grow right because
we're we don't want to have a crappy
boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my
my I didn't have that many jobs I had a
landscaping job which is super boring
just every day just rolling out of grass
and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where
I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team
and I was doing more work than all of
the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I
just kept working and my boss wasn't
happy that because I was overhead
lighting gave me headaches I used to
have to bring in some snacks like food
or popcorn or carrots or something so I
didn't get crazy headaches and my boss
didn't like that I was eating a snack
while I was working
and I got into trouble and almost got
fired
even though I was doing more work than
my entire team combined and it just
really
turned me off of the corporate world to
realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense
I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning
I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life
if you feel like you're in a rut
chances are you haven't learned anything
recently
and so we can we can plan for this you
know you can change your schedule so
that you can focus on learning you can
put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the
greatest benefit my greatest tactic or
strategy for you
for myself
is schedule in learning schedule in
growing
so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos
hopefully for you that you learn and
improve and something Sparks for you but
I'm making for me I'm making for me
because I need it because I need to be
around people who are doing big things
and that I know that every day there's a
video for me
amen it's it's going to be positive it's
going to be uplifting it's going to
spread believe it's going to be
motivational or inspiring it's going to
be Tactical
and I know that on my channel I'm going
to get content that I want and so I've
hired a whole team and built the whole
business basically around making content
that I want to watch and thankfully
enough of you guys want to watch it as
well that it it I can build a business
and have a team
but if I didn't or nobody else cared
about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy may not have
as much intros and all that stuff but I
would still have it for me because I
need it and so
we tend to catch these things too late
because it's not part of our habits and
routines so if you notice you go to an
event or you watch a video and you get
all inspired and you're you got energy
and you're working and things are
amazing cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you
realize what happened to me what how did
I fall off the horse
so quickly where did my energy go has
that happened to you
chances are is because it wasn't
scheduled
you know part of the entrepreneur roller
coaster is because we're bouncing from
one high to the next
without having any scheduled in learning
and growth
and so
my challenge to you would be to try to
figure out how can we schedule in
learning and growing every day
and so it starts with figuring out okay
what medium do you like the most you
know for me I like videos I like being
able to see stuff it just makes it so
much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned
from books
that was the best thing available at the
time now I still have a habit of reading
10 pages at least a night but I don't
get most of my learning from books I get
most of my learning from videos but for
you maybe it's videos if you're watching
this maybe it's books maybe it's
podcasts
something like where do you get the best
learning and then the great thing about
where we are right now is there's so
much content there's so many people to
learn from there's so many people
creating
things out there that you can go and
learn from them
you know if I look at in Eric Thomas or
an Oprah Winfrey they have a similar
message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn
chances are somebody's already making
content on it
and so just go and find them and think
about who you're following right now
like do an audit of who you follow right
now we fall in on YouTube we fall in on
Instagram or Tick Tock or what podcast
you listen to or what books are you
picking up
and how many of those people that you're
following or subscribed to actually make
you feel
ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and
light you up and feel like you're
learning and growing right that's the
whole point of this we're trying to make
growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following
actually make you want to learn and grow
and how many of them are you just
mindlessly scrolling through you know
when you load your Instagram or your
YouTube when you're just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and two hours
have gone by and
not only have you not learned anything
you feel worse about your life because
now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly
entertained yourself but it wasn't even
that entertaining you're like what just
happened to the past two hours of my
life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people
it's not that they're bad people
because that content doesn't light you
up
and then start to be around the people
who do
and the easiest way is through content
so if it's my channel hey good news we
got content every single day for you
you'll never run out of having Chronicle
content to watch but it could be
somebody else is somebody else in
marketing or business or
entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in
to subscribe to those people and be
around them as much as possible and
watch your videos every day schedule it
in for me I go for a walk every morning
call it my believe walk I just like
getting some sun on my face and fresh
air and getting out of the home and it
just gives me some perspective and a
little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll I'll have a video
going
from my channel
and um every morning will be somebody
else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins or Tony Robbins or garyvee or
Tom Billy or whatever and that's what we
do is pull the best clips that I would
learn from and then we share with
everybody else but that's a part of my
daily routines and I've I've seen my own
growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and
consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to
the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and
unsubscribe from the people who just
make you waste time feel worse about
yourself get Envy
or just mindlessly tune out
and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make
learning growing a part of your daily
habit and so where in your calendar can
that fit
if it's over breakfast if it's a morning
walk if it's a afternoon lunch like
where in your calendar can you put
learning from your preferred Style video
podcast books Etc learning it's your
daily calendar if you did that your life
will change if you did that every day
for the next year every day if you did
that if you scheduled that in and you
actually did it and you you watch the
video write a book or listen to podcasts
that inspired you said you know what I
can do this I can do more I can be more
I can accomplish This I Gotta stop
thinking small and stop doubting myself
and stop telling myself that I suck and
I can't do it I can't do this like if
you felt that energy every day from
watching a piece of content that you
intentionally put into your habits
routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform
you will be a totally different person
which then allows you to serve more to
help more to make more money to guide
more to be a leader more all of it all
of your Ambitions and dreams everything
that you want
is all possible
but you have to factor learning and
growing into your daily consistent
habits and routine
energy your energy changes how you show
up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed sad for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not
something new that I'm telling you you
know this the challenges we are not in a
high energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals to follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to depress our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people with a worse version
of your idea
but just more energy and go off and do
it have you ever seen it happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action and just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so if energy is so important then
how do we how do we manage our energy
how do we keep it high and doesn't mean
that you always have to be on top of the
world and you don't have to delude
yourself and say I'm amazing this is
going to be the greatest day of all time
like you don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is be in
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example and today
is a great example because I did not
sleep well last night had had two and a
half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and
just could not could not get to sleep so
I slept from like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did
not sleep until 6 30 in the morning and
that is thankfully a rare occurrence you
know most nights I get eight hours sleep
seven and a half to eight and a half
hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something that would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen so if you
start to train yourself and you create a
calendar and say okay today is a blank
I'm filming this on a Tuesday today's a
Tuesday Tuesday's my video day no matter
what I'm filming videos I gotta film
videos it's got to happen it may not be
my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with the video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside
you know get outside get fresh air get
some sun on my face if you you know you
want to change your energy you want to
shift where you're at and how you're
thinking because it's part physical
energy but also just mental energy how
do you feel about what you're doing and
what's going to happen today and getting
out of your home changing your physical
environment getting some sun on your
face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier a little bit more in
the right energy space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song and you feel chill you put on a
Chill song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all of the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that they came on it would make me move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is you know who
you're feeding your mind with who are
you around who you're surrounded by both
the people in your life you know actual
humans
and the videos that you watch your books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember on the weekend
you gotta guard against this it's crazy
so on the weekend I went to go
meet an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back that oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you can have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
equal effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this way thinking this way I don't like
it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I've applied a lot of the same things I
got it I went outside went outside reset
get some fresh air it always helps me
put on some music songs that I actually
like not some fake song that somebody
else likes and says dance to this it'll
make you feel good as long as I actually
like there are some songs that if it
came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you you would Bob your head or you would
tap your feet or bounce your knee the
songs that just make you do that right
so put on one of those songs it would
naturally make you feel happier
um so I did that too and then in terms
of just gardening against people I made
a note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
which isn't that often but still the
next time I see him I need to remind
myself of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiley and happy had dreams to
the Future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
gets squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but having positive
energy is natural having Sunshine
leading to happiness is natural putting
on music in in dancing and moving is
natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the I was like
okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
that you're on top of the world and then
a fake high every day but a better
energy state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much is your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five be productive
burnout is real but I think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing it's
not just about being busy and keeping
your mind occupied all day you can be
busy and hate your life and get burnt
out if I was an accountant I would hate
my life and burn out in a day because I
don't like being an accountant but doing
this thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go O2 then
there's no wonder why you feel like
you're burning out so I recently came
back from going to Tony Robbins event in
Dallas he invited me to sit in the front
row and uh super blessed and grateful to
have Tony support and I went there with
Alex friend of the channel who helps me
run trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content
I like it I like it more when people
come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a meet-up right I had
an hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour Meetup
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much so how
do you find it how do you find the work
that you love I got a three-step process
called who I how I'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you're unhappy with life it's because
you are living incongruently with your
most important core value so someone
whose core value is freedom as an
example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I
have step two is why so why is your
purpose your purpose comes in your pain
your purpose comes from the deepest
darkest most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your why and your who and your
why are constant they never change your
core values and your purpose are for
life and that's amazing the last step is
how who I how how is your passion how is
how you got out of the pain that you're
in so you struggled with something how
did you get out of it you may not be
fully out of it maybe you're still on
your journey out of it but you're
further ahead than you used to be how
did you get out of it did you read books
did you watch videos did you meditate
did you walk your dogs did you listen to
music like how did you get out of it how
did you get out of it and that is a
recipe that you can teach other people
how you got out of it was not some
random one-off situation you can teach
other people so I struggled a lot with
my business I felt worthless as a human
I wanted to quit I told my partner that
I quit how I got out of it was model and
success I looked at Bill Gates how he
started Microsoft and I applied those
strategies to my business and we started
to see some success 20 years later what
am I doing still modeling success right
I want to learn from Grant I want to
learn from Steve I want to learn from
Kanye I want to learn from these people
it's why keep creating this content how
I got out of it was studying success and
now I teach other people how to study
success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
from your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose for the
mistakes don't hold yourself back most
entrepreneurs never win on social media
because you're not focused you post
everywhere every now and then with
content that is below what you're
capable of making chances are you
wouldn't even subscribe to you on your
own channels if you weren't you if you
wouldn't subscribe to you you can't
expect others to subscribe to you either
we're gonna fix that in this video so I
make all my content for me I want to
spread more believe in myself self and
in doing that I then share it with the
world and and thankfully you guys watch
it you guys enjoy it and I can build a
business off of it but even if nobody
else liked it I'd be making it just for
myself so that I had the content because
this is my own personal development
professional growth series and so I love
learning from Gary I love being around
Gary I love being around Steve and while
we don't have a lot of content on
epigenini but I love I love being around
you know while my parents don't have a
YouTube channel either Howard Schultz
Kanye I love I love being around more
successful people mission-driven
entrepreneurs who are trying to make a
change in the world when I'm around it
it pulls me up it makes me want to do
bigger things
and so I'm inspired by my own content
when I'm when I'm going to Instagram and
I'm posting a story part of my morning
routine every morning is I post a story
if you see the black and white pictures
that's the current iteration right now
I'll take a picture of myself and I'll
have a message on top of it it'll say
the day and then a message that's a
message for me
it's a message that I need to remind
myself of so just before doing the
picture I'll think what do I need to do
it's not even about Sharon it's about
what do I want for myself what do I need
to remind myself of today right what do
I need to remind myself of today so that
I show up that I step up that I don't
Coast that don't just take it easy that
I live to my potential today today today
today today right today matters
and so I'll make that message and share
it and then hopefully it touches and
inspires other people as well
that's what's missing from so many
people who are creating content you're
creating content that is one way too
self-promotional you're creating content
that
it barely speaks to yourself and you
just posting it and you feel crushed
under the weight of having to manage all
these different social media accounts
and none of them doing well and then you
ask why am I not growing and why am I
not getting followers and why am I
getting the results that I need so I'm a
big believer in being able to have the
accounts everywhere but not actually
being consistently posting everywhere
because I'd actually rather have you
focus on one platform at a time make it
amazing make a crush start winning there
before you expand and build a team and
go to the other platforms but at the
core is you have to be posting content
whether it's videos written podcasts
right audio whatever the format is you
have to be posting content that you're
proud of you have to be posting content
just like any other product or service
if you're selling a product or service
you want to be able to recommend it to
your mom
if she had that problem if she needed
your product or service you would
recommend it to her because you believe
in it so much right you have to believe
in what you're doing you have to believe
in what you're making not just because
my one word is belief but because it's
actually important so would you follow
you are you proud of the work that
you're putting up even though you know
you're capable of more yes great but are
you proud of what you made is that the
was what you posted today the best the
best of what you could do right now
given your current capabilities
resources and skill set yes awesome keep
going no
work it work harder Today show up room
number seven believe you've got a great
idea
you know it can change the world you
know it can have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know it can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself and so
here's what's happened why well it's
because you've tried and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and you maybe saw a little bit
tiny results but then you lose the
motivation and you stop you've never
stayed with anything long enough to
actually let it see results and so you
built up this pattern inside yourself
that says I can't do it the idea is
great but I can't do it that's really at
the core if you really believe that you
could do it and you really believed in
the idea you'd be doing it and crushing
it so it's the biggest difference is why
lack of belief is the world's biggest
problem the only thing you're missing is
actual sustained momentum against your
ideas because if you believe that you
could do it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world but
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it
now this is where we have to start
talking about making decisions with your
head versus your heart
so your head only understands a world
that exists your head is logical it's
practical and so whatever's been done
can be done again right it's logical and
so if you've got a job at some company
you know you can make X thousands of
dollars a year that's that's safe that's
logical that's practical you know it can
be done it exists other people have done
it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path and it's not
necessarily wrong it's not malicious
they're not trying to hurt you
it's just fear-based and so it's small
you never create amazing things when
you're living in a fear-based state and
that's what you're doing when you make
big decisions with your head because
your head only understands a practical
world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's never existed before your heart
is where all the artists lives all the
all the game changers live all the
people who end up making massive change
in the world that's where they live
they're creating something new they say
I see something that other people don't
see and I can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where I know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where I know
you're at the problem is living inside
your head instead of living inside your
heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days when you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days I'm gonna
switch my hand my hand's getting tired
I'm holding the video you'll have some
days where you'll actually feel that way
like maybe I can I can be the person I
am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up and you get inspired you
had a great dream something happens you
have this moment where you just feel
bold powerful and stopper and say
today's my day I'm gonna go off and do
it and crushing right we've all had
those moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself I can't do this I
didn't go to school for this I don't
have the money for this I don't have the
talent for this I'm not good enough for
this I'm I'm not brave enough for
creatures enough for this right that's
all you're ahead talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is you're heading your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on YouTube that you want to fill in a
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
and so your head is always going to say
whoa whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're gonna listen
to your head and the people around you
will tell you listen to your head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't your heart has to decide
the big decisions in your life treat you
go move to that other country or other
City should you go marry that person or
not should you go take that job or not
should you go start that business or not
big decisions with your heart and then
you use your head to help you figure out
the how
I always find it so funny when people
are thinking well should I do that
business or not or should I marry that
person or not and they make a they make
a list or make a checklist
and you write down pros and cons right
never make a decision that's big in your
life based off of objective pros and
cons because you're making it using the
wrong part of your body
because you might really love somebody
and you come with all these lists and
you got
80 80 cons on that list and only one pro
or maybe that one pro is all you need
same thing with the business there's a
million reasons why your business is not
going to work out you sit there and make
a list of of pros and cons there should
be way more cons there's a million
reasons why you're not going to win an 8
why you will and the people who go off
and win only focus on the eight
making a list of pros and cons to help
you make big decisions in life is one of
the stupidest things you can do
straight up
now your head is very important
your head
helps you accomplish your goals but only
once your heart's decided
so your heart allows you to make the big
decisions I want this to happen in my
life no negotiation this is going to
happen
and then from there you use your head to
figure out how to do it
right once your head is not fighting in
your heart once your head is understood
oh
he's serious she's serious okay crap how
do we actually make this happen now
that's when you use your head because
you're a smart person and you need your
head aligned to help you accomplish your
big goals so if I want to go off and
build my YouTube channel get 10 million
subscribers that's happening
when I first started YouTube 11 years
ago there was no educational content
there were no 15 minute videos on
YouTube it was it was all memes and and
stupid videos and cats and
just not this not this at all
and it took me too long to listen to my
heart quite frankly you know I loved it
and so I kept doing it and and you know
part of my own back for myself was that
thankfully I kept going I wasn't as
consistent as I am now but I kept going
I didn't give up even though there were
no signs that I would have success right
my first video got three comments in one
year and one was my mom one was my
sister and one was some random dude I
wasn't getting traction
I was still looking back at some of my
old videos yesterday and a lot of them
no no comments right like one video 35
views zero comments man I guess I spent
a lot of time making that video
and so I kept going
because there was something inside me
that said I need to keep doing this
I wish I kept going faster and it's my
wish for you too right now with your
business with your idea with your crazy
goals I wish you keep going but I wish
you'd go faster on it that you decide
with your heart to say I am making this
happen
and you say head listen to me we're
making this happen now you're the smart
one help me figure out how to actually
do it so to get to my 10 million
subscribers how do I do it
and every day I'm using my brain to help
me do it and hopefully you are too
when your head and your heart are
fighting when your goals your Ambitions
your dreams
are fighting every day what you think is
practical logical possible you're just
gonna be stuck
very slow growth very some momentum
knowing you're capable of more but just
stuck because you're fighting yourself
the biggest problem is you're just
fighting yourself but when you can let
go when you can say my heart is going to
help me make the big decisions in my
life and my head's gonna help me figure
out how
magical things start to happen and
that's my wish for you
flip the switch you can choose at any
moment
positivity you can choose at any moment
gratitude you can choose at any moment
service you can choose to change your
mindset in in an instant if you wanted
to the challenge is we're so living in
our subconscious mode that we don't we
don't catch it soon enough we don't
think the action that we're proud of and
then we regret it yeah we regret it
later on this morning I woke up really
early I'm very tired I woke up at 3 45
a.m for some reason don't know why uh
look at my look at my watch like 3 45
a.m what oh man okay try to go back to
sleep toss turn for about an hour and
then I got up like okay you know it's 4
45 it's almost five you know let's let's
get up and I got to work and started
doing things and then the crash hit me
the crash hit me just not enough sleep
and everything inside me wanted to shut
down you know I wanted to just take the
complete break not do my walk in the
morning not not take the dogs out while
the dogs have to go out but not do my
routine not do any of my usual stuff not
record videos today's a Tuesday round
record it's video recording day
and it's in these moments those trying
times that you have to decide who you
want to be you have to decide if you
want to choose to be positive choose to
live in gratitude choose to live in
productivity choose live in service or
not what would the future you think of
your actions right now
and I think 95 of the time the answer is
to push a little harder move the brake
line forward right where where you would
normally take a break move that forward
just a little bit move the brake line
forward a touch
and five percent of the time you have to
be more gentle on yourself
when my family dog passed away when I
broke my neck when you know all sorts of
things have happened to me just like
they've happened to you sometimes the
answer is to give yourself a little more
grace
to recognize how far you've come
everything that you've done with the
limited amount of resources and time
that you have
but I think if we default to that then
we default to staying stuck and staying
small because life is going to throw so
many different challenges at you
so I think 95 of the time that's the
five percent right five percent of time
you give yourself more grace you let
yourself off the hook you take the day
off you do whatever you need especially
if you're struggling with grief
if you're struggling with grief I think
you just have to work your way through
it you have to give yourself a lot of
Grace and a lot of time and and it will
get better and and just please don't go
through it alone
but almost everything else
usually the answer is to keep going
because it'll make you more proud
because you're teaching yourself that
you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome
so this morning I woke up I got out of
bed I was instantly productive like okay
I'm wired for whatever reason here we go
let's go answering my Discord messages
if you're not on Discord Evan
carmichael.biz I'm there every morning
it's super fun answering questions it's
such a great community so I did my
Discord I looked at the responding to my
emails and Twitter and
um I got all my work done super early
then the crash hits and then Nina wakes
up
and it's time to make videos and
I don't want to make videos
you know I'm I'm tired I feel like I'm
gonna let myself down and I feel like
I'm Gonna Let You Down is yawn's answer
it's not that I don't want to make
videos because I don't enjoy them I feel
like it won't be at my best and then I
won't I won't create something that I'm
proud of and I'm gonna let you guys down
that's really the internal narrative you
know I'm gonna create a subpar product
and people who watch are gonna be
disappointed because
I take it as a big responsibility that
you know some of you start your day
every day with one of my videos that
means a lot to me it's
not a burden but a responsibility that I
take and I want to make something that
I'm proud of and that helps you improve
your life today at least gives you a
little kick start you know like let's go
let's have a great day I want to be able
to bring that energy and and I I was
worried that this morning I wouldn't be
able to do it
but you know what that's not a good
enough reason
it's not a good enough reason
as long as you believe those reasons you
will never create anything great because
if you wait to have the right energy the
perfect timing the right amount of sleep
the the perfect cell phone or video
camera with the perfect microphone and
you know
just
it will never happen you will never
create anything great
and so I had to remind myself of that
because you can choose positivity at any
moment you can choose service you can
choose gratitude you can choose
productivity at any moment you can
choose it if you want to if you really
want to you can instead of defaulting to
the negative patterns and so Nina got up
I told her I was tired told I had a
rough night she said she slept super
well
it's like oh that's really that's really
bad but I slept so well the great well
I'm very happy for you but I'm very
tired right now and
um
right away then that's okay so when are
when are we going out
because Nina's shopping at Costco I mean
I'm in the Costco parking lot I think
you can't make content like I'm sitting
here in the Costco parking lot filming
videos for you guys and I asked her when
are we going out when are you gonna when
do you want to go shopping because I'm
gonna get my phone ready and I'm gonna
make some videos
and in that instant I decided and then
committing to her made it happen
and here I am in the car making the
videos happen and hopefully there's
there's something good and I'm not
disappointing you guys but I'm making
myself proud at the very least
when you show up when the world's
against you or when you've had a rough
day or when you don't feel like it or
when you got a nasty comment or you're
in a weird mood for whatever reason you
still show up like when it's hard
when it's hard and you still show up
that's when you build the most self-love
and self-belief
self-confidence that's where it comes
from doing difficult things
and what it does is it reinforces that
as your identity
that this is who you become so the next
time something comes up you can handle
it aim a little bit more because they're
moving the brake line forward
slippery slope to fall down with every
time you come up against something
difficult you don't do it
even if other people are telling you how
great you are that you can do it if you
tell yourself that you can't do it then
the next time it comes up you reinforce
that you can't do it and you can't do it
and you can't do it and what you've
built is an automatic pattern of you
don't follow through that you can't do
it that when you set a goal you're not
going to follow through on it you know
you're going to start and then you're
going to stop that when something gets
hard you know you're going to give up on
it or that you're going to quit in a
couple days because that's the pattern
that you've built to yourself and the
pattern becomes the identity
right if you want to switch your
identity it's totally possible
you could you could be the person who
always follows through you could be the
person who always steps up you can be
the person who always delivers you can
be the person who always brings their
best you could be that person you may
not believe that yet but you can be that
person so how do you get there
how does that become your new identity
there are two things that really matter
first is to be around other people who
are like that
one of the reasons why I was able to get
up and do this today was because
I watch John Assaraf and Steve Jobs and
Oprah Winfrey and these people every day
now I happen to know John Ashraf he's
become a friend uh I don't know Steve
Jobs or Oprah Winfrey
um I don't know for yet so we'll see
Steve I've missed my chance
but
hanging around them even if it's
virtually even if you you don't know who
John you don't you can't call him up and
ask him a question or you can't call up
Oprah great you can still learn from
them you can still be around them and
the more that you see other people doing
things the more you want to go do it
yourself have you ever been to a movie
and you got inspired and you see
somebody win the race like
yeah the underdog you like I love the
Underdog Story you ever seen Underdog go
off and win and then it makes you want
to go not run a race but do your thing
like you ever been inspired by somebody
else's
overcoming of obstacles story
right
so it's the same thing if you're around
successful people
and you see how they're doing it and you
see how they rise up against the
obstacles in their in their life
it gives you encouragement and hope and
belief that you can too where most of
the people that we're surrounded by
are already giving up they get they're
not even trying they gave up years ago
right and so when we're at our weakest
moments
when we're around people or consuming
content that reinforces our negative
beliefs
the people say okay yeah yeah just take
a break yeah don't do this you weren't
meant to do this anyway like why did you
think you could ever do this just go and
and play a computer game or just go and
watch some you know trash TV right
just gonna get distracted for the day
pretend like you're doing stuff but you
know you're not doing anything that's
going to make you proud right just
scroll through Instagram all day like
everybody else right when you're around
that then it's so easy for you to fall
down that rabbit hole when you're not at
your A game so you can you can
manufacture it by being around the
people again if you don't know them
personally then just in your environment
some videos you watch is why it's why I
make this content that I can introduce
you to people and and keep bringing you
ideas and belief that hopefully inspires
you daily to lift you up when when you
might be having a rough day
so that's step one step two is you have
to then do something people say
motivation doesn't last well that's true
but
the point of motivation isn't for it to
last the point of motivation is to give
you the courage to go to the thing so
I'm I'm waking up this morning early
right Nina's still sleeping she wakes up
but before she wakes up while I'm doing
my work while I'm hanging on Discord
first the discord's super fun and
connect with entrepreneurs and so it's
it's already getting me in in a good
mood
and then I started watching videos from
my own top 10 Channel
so as I'm working I've got who do I
listen to today
um I had Bill Gates on
uh Bezos on
uh I had an old Richard Branson one on
and their voices are are in my head as
I'm working and so then when Nina gets
up it's like okay let's go let's go to
work because I had Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates in my ear this
morning right and I don't know any of
them personally
and so you could do that too right but
the whole point of that motivation is
then to give you the courage to go Act
so by listening to them in the morning
listen to them is not enough right
that's not enough you got all inspired
and motivated to not do anything
listen to them then gave me the boldness
to say Evan you need to make videos
today you said you're gonna do it let's
go do it I know you're afraid of
disappointing people you're gonna make
it the best you can let's go
because I imagine what would Bill Gates
tell me or what would Jeff Bezos tell me
what would Richard Branson tell me they
tell me something like that I think I
hope I don't think they're gonna say you
know what just quit probably not right
and then that got me to go out and now
I'm here and I'm making the content I'm
doing the thing
so it's the motivation that you need to
inject into yourself
plus the action
and when you do that enough you start to
build the new habit so instead of the
pattern being I don't follow through I
always quit I always get up you start to
build a new pattern that says
I rise to the occasion I overcome these
obstacles I defeat that little voice
inside my head I call it the little man
I beat the little man
right and when you do that consistently
then that becomes your new default
pattern that the next challenge that
comes in you say okay let's go what's
next I'm ready I want the next Mountain
let's go climbing
right
so it's totally possible but it starts
with the belief that at any point
you can choose positivity at any point
you can choose gratitude at any point
you can choose service no matter what's
going on in your life right now there
are millions of people who have it way
worse than you
and you can choose
the light and you can choose to help
and you can choose to inspire
and doing that will not only serve the
world but make you a lot more proud of
yourself too rule number nine stay truly
present the key to enjoying your life is
being present the key to focusing is
being present the key to feeling like
you're valuable and what you do matters
is being present being present is at the
core to a lot of great things but a lot
of people really struggle to stay
present because what are you doing most
people spend most of their time
either thinking about the past
or thinking about the future and not
even in a positive way you spend time
thinking about the past living in regret
of all the things that you could have
done you could have said you should have
done you should have said I wish I did
that I wish that video I made didn't
suck you know I wish I wish I wish I
wish why didn't I and we beat ourselves
up does that sound familiar is that you
maybe even a little a little bit or we
spend our time being anxious about the
future
I think as entrepreneurs we get excited
about the future of where we could go
and what we could build and that's
that's the fun daydreaming part
but a lot of thinking about the future
is stress inducing it's anxiety it's
it's worrying about what could go wrong
all the millions of things that could go
wrong that maybe never go wrong but
we're still worried about them right
again does that sound somewhat familiar
when you are stuck living in the past or
living in the future you're never
obviously present but you're not happy
you're not productive you're not focused
you're not creating you're not serving
none of it and you're not fulfilled
I look at people who want to get started
on YouTube for example or entrepreneurs
are trying to launch their business
and
people made maybe one video or two
videos and because it didn't work out
you made a video and you felt
embarrassed by yourself or you launched
a product and somebody had one bad piece
of feedback if we live in that same
negativity over and over and over and
over and over again people ask me well
what happens when you have a bad video
what happens when your video bombs I was
speaking at Brendan burchard's
influencer Summit yesterday
and
somebody asked me what do you do when a
video doesn't take off or do well like
well lots of my videos don't take off
and do well I think I don't know which
ones are gonna blow up the ones that
have blown up surprise me like that's
the one that blew up I love this one so
much more
how do I keep going because I'm looking
to the next one like I'm worried I'm
working on videos now I don't know what
I released yesterday or the day before
the day before
because I'm making new content
think about how you got over a
relationship well you when you get into
a new relationship it's easy to forget
about your last relationship it's
thinking about what you're doing now
and if you have nothing right now what
do you do if there's nothing to do right
now you spend your time in regret about
the past or worried about the future
it's not enough action happening right
now I don't care about videos that
failed in the past because I'm going to
be making tons more another one comes
out today and another one tomorrow
another one tomorrow and it's it's a
moment to reflect and say hey okay I
could have done better on that one or
why didn't this one do well okay this
moment here that sucked perfect I'm
making one today I'll make it better
at least that's the intent maybe I don't
achieve it but that's the intent and we
show up without intent every day you
will eventually make it better
most people get too caught up on on the
mistakes that they made in the past it's
in the past
you did the best you could with what
you've got remind yourself of that
you did the best you could
with what you had
great don't be so hard on yourself keep
making
because the worst thing you can do is
quit now the worst thing you can do is
stop now because when you look back on
your life when you're 120 that you'll
regret that you you stopped you regret
that you had a chance you had a moment
you could have done something and you
didn't like that's the biggest regret of
all
not taking any kind of action not the
mistakes that you made you we don't
regret really the things that we did
most of the things that people regret
are the things they did not do
most people's biggest regrets are not
taking enough action
letting that little man voice inside
their head
tell them all the reasons why they
weren't going to win
convincing themselves that they weren't
capable
and as a result they stopped when they
wish they had the courage the strength
the tenacity to keep going
right that could be you could you could
you could get going you keep going you
could stay present you could make the
next thing
and at the same time A lot of people are
then also worried about the future
well what if I make this and it doesn't
work out I was talking to people again
yesterday about their YouTube channels
and the same person asked me
well what if it
doesn't work out
like what if I make videos and nobody
sees them so what if nobody sees my
videos and then the next question was
what if people see my videos and they
don't like me
so this person at the same time is
afraid of people not seeing their videos
and people seeing their videos
so how does that make any sense right
this is this is the loop that we get
stuck in you're afraid of people not
seeing you and you're afraid of people
seeing you like you can't win the mental
dialogue we have with ourselves we can't
win
that's not possible
we need to start to flip that we need to
we need to rewire ourselves
and that starts again with being present
like you can't control what the outcome
is going to be in the future but you
can't control what you're doing right
now
if you can switch so that you are mostly
present
not really thinking about the past
unless it's gratitude right if you can
flip the regret of the past to gratitude
right and if you can switch the anxiety
for the future to excitement or vision
that's when you really start to win
somebody came to an event that I did in
Toronto and asked me
these guys drove up from Boston to do a
podcast with me and then stuck around
for my event and they asked me how much
of your time do you spend
percentage-wise
living in the past present future
and I said zero percent passed
85 percent present
15 future
and the 15 is
is Vision what I want to create you know
as entrepreneurs we have to be a little
bit forward thinking but it's it's 85
present
I don't even know what day it is
like it's present not even present to
today but present to this moment I don't
know what day it is I don't know what
time it is
I know what I'm doing after this all I
know is I'm here right now with you guys
and that allows for Focus that allows
for happiness that allows her purpose
that allows for life to give you so many
gifts when you're not stuck living in
the past or the future
so how do you do it how do you how do
you get there
I think the best thing you can do
is every time you catch yourself
drifting daydreaming forward or back in
a negative way
you catch it every time you can catch it
you won't catch it most of the time so
don't put this impossibly High burden on
yourself that every time I'm I'm
thinking about the past and I'm living
in regret I'm Gonna Catch and do
something about it you won't catch it
you won't catch it this is this is
Decades of un unwiring our brain right
it's fine don't don't have when you're
starting something new don't have crazy
expectations that you have to get it
perfect or you're a failure
right this is the problem not just with
this one exercise but with everything
don't expect to be great out of the gate
you won't you're just starting you're at
the beginning why do you think you're
going to be fantastic and because the
first time it doesn't work out perfectly
then we quit that is not how it works
right you you need to expect to suck at
the beginning that's okay
that's how you learn something every
time you can catch yourself drifting
you're you're living in the past in
regret or future being stressed out just
try to bring it back to right now
just bring her back to the present and
focus on anything focus on a physical
object you can you could I could focus
on my coffee like how do I how can you
get present right now you focus on the
coffee wow look at this coffee cup you
know it's tall it's red I'm I'm grateful
for the beverage inside here uh I like
that they have sleep oh it's got a maple
leaf on it right like this is all I'm
being present right now with a cup of
coffee it is warm I can feel the
sensation on my hands
I can taste it in my mouth right
where most of the time even when you're
eating something most of the time when
you're eating something you're usually
focused on something else right you're
eating while you're on your phone you're
eating while you're watching a video
you're eating while you're doing
something now so not ever actually
enjoying the food because we're thinking
about what's next
so every time you can catch it you just
try to bring it back to the moment so
right now
and then what's gonna happen is the more
you do that
the more you'll catch it
so right now maybe you're catch it one
percent of the time but the more you do
that and practice that and just pick one
thing to focus on that's in your
environment or focus on your breath
right it's why meditation works so well
with a mantra or breath work because it
gives you something to focus on when
you're first starting out with being
present and focus it's helpful to have
somewhere to put your attention because
focus on nothing doesn't feel like very
practical advice to the beginner trying
to figure this out so you focus on your
breath and anytime your mind wanders
bring her back to the breath every time
you get stressed or anxious or worried
or what you're going to do next bring it
back to the breath every time you get
bored
bring it back to the breath right the
breath could be anything the breath
could be the cup of coffee look at the
cup of coffee feel the cup of coffee
every time you get distracted you're
worrying about work or your life back to
the cup of coffee back to your Mantra
right all of that can work it's just
picking something to ground you back in
being in the present
and again the more you catch it and the
more you do it the more you'll catch the
next one
and the more you're doing again the next
time
it's a skill that you learn you're
retraining your brain how to work
and what you'll find is
the more you can do that and the more
you practice it
bit by bit
day by day
you'll find yourself
having less stress
being more productive
staying more focused
caring less about what other people
think about you
and overall being happier
and what that does is free you up to
actually go and do the work that's
inside you the genius that you've got
to put out to the world
and serve
being present
is the key to unlocking your happy life
less time living and regret about the
past less time living in the stress of
the future and anxiety for what may come
and more time focused on what can you do
right now
today in this moment
to be proud of yourself
and live your best life rule number 10
the last one before our very special
bonus Club learn to make money if you
think money is scarce you hoard it
because you believe that no more money
will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education
and as a result we didn't have you know
money for other things and
um were my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and Order
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
either for ourselves or for other people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
markets invest in the assets just invest
invest invest invest invest invest
the that's a good that's a great good
mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping about a very expensive
purse we bought a Chanel bag and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that we did so much work
in our business you can you can go and
afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
support our family and things that they
needed or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit this might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how are we going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be a hundred bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm gonna buy it or
you're going to go buy somebody a meal
or you're gonna go and give a homeless
person a hundred dollars right like
you're gonna you're gonna do something
with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks ten thousand bucks like
you know whatever it is I'm not
advocating you go drain your bank
account and just go crazy and buy a
Chanel bag you know but allocating a
certain percentage every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so this
gives that little extra bit of
motivation and incentive right to get
out there and start to do it to allocate
a certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love
my view on something great hanging
around me more often is lots of videos
you love Grant cardone's view or
garyvee's view or Oprah's view on
something the more you hang around them
and watch their content and read their
books and listen to their speeches the
more you're going to start to adopt that
same belief system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos of the people who believe the
thing that you want to believe because
otherwise you get pulled back down
because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are
so if you want to change where you are
you have to change the environment and
it used to be that you had to you have
to really change you have to go
somewhere else you had to move out you
had to find a mentor to hang out with
and have coffee with consistently now
you can do it through it through YouTube
I've been inspired by tons of mentors
who have never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day be
an intentional with that to say this is
this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
I probably still should be more generous
than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change
you don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing if stuck
it's small keeps you frustrated keeps
you knowing that you're capable of more
and being too afraid to go take the
action and until you can break that
pattern of negative self-talk
nothing will happen and so we're gonna
fix that in this video I think as soon
as we come up with ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
gonna happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out fear
of being seen fear of not being seen and
it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah I've made I don't know how many
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
fourteen thousand videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before I sit down to make the videos I
procrastinate a little bit
in today's filming session I'm here at
my wife's Acupuncture Clinic she's
inside getting her acupuncture done I
joined her sitting in the car and it
probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time you ever had these
thoughts you know he's like you want to
do something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you him and you ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know has that happened I
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
it is a little longer I'd usually be
like five ten minutes it took a little
bit longer 15 minutes today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
what if I just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I sit in front of the camera
to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it the
difference is how quickly can you shift
how can you get unstuck because most
people just stay stuck they stay
constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not coming out
constipated
stay stuck so how do you do it how do
you shift it here are a couple things
that helped me that I hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
it's you know people don't want to floss
I mean I floss I've built the habit of
flossing twice a day most people don't
floss and the concept is just floss one
tooth and once you've lost one tooth
you'll floss the rats probably right
just get your running shoes on and go
for a walk and once you're walking
you'll probably do more than you know
the two minutes that you set yourself
into mind like just do two minutes so
for me is just make the first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing
come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing
they'll make it some giant Endeavor that
you have to go off and Chase it's nice
to have big goals and big Ambitions and
Big Dreams but sometimes they're too big
and then you feel like you can't do it
and you need venture capital and you
need a team and you need all sorts of
things before you can do anything on it
it's great to have that big goal and
what are you gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building up momentum
it's just so much so much so much so
much easier so the challenge for today
is just just find one small simple easy
way to get started it doesn't have to be
amazing it doesn't have to be great it's
just the first step once you get your
first step it's so much easier to take
the second so that's one just start
building some immediate momentum number
two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if this
feels more conversational I don't know
it's all it's all just a a head game
but it feels more I feel like I'm
talking to a friend hello how you doing
I'm Evan if you
it feels more conversational and natural
for me I like having the sun on my face
you know it just feels better and so
changing your state can be a good way if
you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
helps I promise you have you ever had a
uh you're thinking really negatively
um you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room where you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus to
that is music music I should have done
that today music is
the fastest way to change your state so
while I was sitting here in the car for
15 minutes procrastinating making these
videos instead of thinking hey I should
go and check in on my team and see how
they're doing underneath like logically
that makes sense like how's my team
doing I'm being a good boss you know
good manager a good friend I should
check in on them see how they're doing
it's going to move my goals forward of
course because if they're waiting on me
for something right logically all that
makes sense underneath it is just again
the fear that my videos won't be good
enough so I need to feel productive I
need to feel value valuable to myself I
need to feel worthy so I'm going to
spend my time there instead of making
videos right I should have put on music
when that was happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to
uh I should have put on some music like
put on some music that makes you move
and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple
from my example in my office I have five
pictures on the wall and they all tell a
different story remind me of who I want
to be I've got Steve Jobs on the wall
who reminds me to be a Visionary I've
got AP giannini on the wall who's my
favorite entrepreneur of all time and he
reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest Meme and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting
the crime of lack of belief
right and and so just somebody commented
on my hoodie yesterday's like you're
always wearing you're always on brand
you're always wearing your hoodie it's
like it's not just it's not just when I
show up to make videos this is this is
this is what I wear because I'm a I'm a
superhero going to work and when I put
this on in the morning it's like I'm I'm
I'm Batman going to work or uh uh you
know police officer going to work it's
like this is this is what I do
and
and I'm a lot more for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
and so as a conscious choice to say okay
what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that use ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is that this is who I want to
be this is who I want to be this is who
I want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say
yeah you you can't do that and here's
all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons you are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid that we're going to be judged
we're afraid of disappointing people
we're afraid of not being loved we're
afraid that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm gonna go do the
thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in six months and 12 months you
can it's possible you can your mission
is worthy and Noble and should happen
and you're the one to do it you you're
the one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum
just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step people aren't afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing in
front of other people you'll sing in the
shower but you won't sing on the street
corner you'll record a video but you'll
never release it you'll be your own
biggest critic but you won't at the same
time also be your own biggest fan that
needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge for the event and my first
reaction was oh my God I can't charge
for this event right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason then I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free what a tour this year
shouldn't be free and so I had to do it
I had to step into the fear you have to
step into the fear and do it because you
need to attack the thing that you're
afraid of especially when it's related
to other people right I'm not afraid of
failing I'm afraid of failing in front
of other people right I can suck all day
here in the office but I don't want to
suck in front of somebody else I don't
want to make people feel like whether
they're spending 50 bucks to come and
see me that was on tour or 2 000 bucks
to come see me at my thought Lucifer out
of me here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur makes you a thousand times
better as an entrepreneur because that's
the same fear that you face in your
business that fear of going on that game
show on the cruise ship that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on on the street corner making
a video great go do it if that if that
is scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
you come on the other side you'll come
up with more strength and then you'll
start seeing things happen in your
business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you've had
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness I
don't think people are bold all day long
right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I look at
people coming to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you those are the decisions you have
to follow through on and embrace and
then your head talks you down from them
the head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to do it you have to start
building momentum you have to start
committing to some other people embrace
the Bold ideas recognize that those
aren't the crazy ideas those crazy ideas
that come up with your affiliate mold
are not crazy those are actually the
best ones for you you're just buried
under a pile of garbage of limited
beliefs on top of you those are the
things you have to go chase down and
when it gets hard when it gets difficult
when you want to quit remind yourself
this idea came to me when I was feeling
bold I have to do it because I do bold
things you teach yourself step number
two is expect to suck this is where it
gets super liberating expect to suck the
first time you do anything expect to
suck why do you expect to be great the
first time out what do you expect your
first video that you make to be great
it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
and making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long your first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill still you suck at the
beginning and it's really hard because
you know what looks good if you want to
be a basketball player you know what a
good basketball player looks like if you
want to be a YouTuber you know what a
good YouTube video looks like but then
you can't do it yet your first one sucks
and that's where most people quit
because they expect to be good they're
worried about looking bad in front of
other people they're not good the first
time out and so then they never go back
to it and this is what happens when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying
as adults how often you try new things
how often are you willing to risk
failure to risk losing to risk looking
like a fool
you don't want them so you're not trying
as much anymore and you ever find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life and some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love expect to suck
but if you love the process of it you
will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you've
forgot
this thing that you remember the stuff
that you connected with that you like
more so when you love something you're
going to just learn a lot faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos and I'm trying my best maybe it's
not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying
I'm proud of my effort I'm proud of the
attempt most people tie their software
to winning to the results to the money
to the gold medal to the to the whatever
right to the YouTube to the plaques back
there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself Worth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you you're capable of
way more your people doing something
much bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're proud of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because we're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing you want to risk looking
like an idiot
you have to if you want the life that
you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
but get up try again be proud of your
effort every single day you're not
changing because you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to do
it all alone you can have a moment of
inspiration moment of this is the day
I'm gonna change it all and then when
your environment and people around you
don't support you in doing it and you're
doing it all alone you lose momentum the
next day that momentum is gone and the
next day the momentum is is absolutely
zero have you ever you ever been there
until you get the people around you to
support you to create a circle where you
can feel like you do not have to do this
alone
you won't change
and you'll stay stuck knowing that
you're capable of more
and frustrated with yourself with the
lack of momentum I run this challenge
inside my movement makers program and
every month we have to talk about a
certain topic movement makers is For
Thought leaders it's people who are they
have a message they have a mission they
want to get out to the world your story
matters let's get it out there and go
come on
but it's really hard to share your story
and it's really hard to make videos and
it's really hard to put yourself out
there and you have these moments where
you want to do it and you feel on top of
the world like yes I'm ready and then
and then what then all the insecurities
and fears and doubts creep in and
as I was noticing people and Movie
Makers not making enough content I
decided to do a challenge and the
challenge is once a month we pick a
topic
and this month's topic is courage
and what you have to do is make a solo
video that's 10 minutes long you have to
make a lead magnet to help grow your
business and you have to do three
collaboration videos and most people do
Instagram lives they collaborate with
each other and all of a sudden
[Music]
people who took up the challenge started
making content all of a sudden the
excuses went away the I don't know what
gear to buy I don't know what camera to
use I don't know what microphone I don't
know what to talk about my story is not
good enough I'll start next week I'll
start next year I'll start next month
I'll start on my birthday I'll start on
January 1st I'll start on Monday I'll
start I'll start next month right all of
the all of the excuses all of a sudden
went away
because you're not doing it alone
because all of those reasons that are
holding people back that are holding you
back you want to do something bigger
all of the reasons that are actually
holding you back are not The Logical
ones that are in your head
right the idea that you're not making
content because you don't know what
phone to use or what camera to use or
what I'm sit I'm making these videos for
my channel on my phone I'm I'm in my car
at my wife's acupuncturist she's getting
acupuncture done right now in the
building right next to me and so I'm
making content in my car you can too
right they're logical reasons why you
are not doing a thing that you want to
do right that you say is important to
you there's logical reasons that you are
buying
you've you've you believe them they are
actual reasons but they're not good
enough reasons and underneath those
reasons why you're not doing the thing
that you need to do is just that you're
afraid
it's just fear
and suffering through fear alone
is really really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's not that you can't do
it it's just immensely difficult and
most people won't most people won't
follow through most people don't follow
through because they are alone
in this journey you might have people
around you you might you might have
great parents friends a spouse
but if you feel like you're walking the
journey all by yourself
it's just insanely difficult to actually
follow through and get the results that
you want
the good news is you can change it right
the good news is hey we don't have to
stay stuck the good news is you can
change your circle and I'm going to
share a couple ideas in this video of
how to do it so
number one
I like to collect good people
collect good people think about the
people around you in your life how many
of them make you feel happier more
energetic more positive and you may not
have many people you know there you may
not have someone like that
great
think about the people who you've ever
met
maybe it was at a conference maybe an
event maybe a lunch or dinner
um some kind of party a friend of a
friend
I
find ways to spend more time with good
people I remind myself that I like to
collect good people and as someone who's
shy and introverted
that's that's
not my default state
I don't think to call people I don't
think the message people I don't I don't
um default to being around people but
when there's somebody whose energy I
really love and I leave the conversation
feeling more uplifted than when I went
in
then I I try to find ways to spend more
time with that person and maybe it leads
to a business maybe it leads to some
kind of opportunity maybe just leads to
another conversation but think about the
people who you have met at some point in
your life maybe not the people around
you right now but an old high school
friend or again somebody at an event or
a club or some meeting that you met that
you really like their energy and their
Vibe I'll lean in on the awkward and say
hey do you want to go grab a coffee I'd
love to learn more about your story
or I really love your energy
do you want to go and get some lunch
together
it feels super awkward but chances are
they need somebody too
and if you be the first one to do the
Outreach and say hey I'd love to learn
more about you see the people who you
don't really know that well but you'd
like to
and you can even say that when you're
talking to them hey I don't really know
you that well but I'd like to
and lean in on the awkwardness be the
first one to go off and do it so so
think about the people in your network
people who you have met one-offs
meetings
who filled you with that positivity and
and fight for more time with them
because if you had four people
and you met everybody once a month
that's once a week now you're meeting
some amazing human
whether it's coffee whether it's lunch
whether it's a zoom call whether it's
actually forming some kind of business
together
there are people who you've come across
who
are the support that you need and you
need to do the Outreach to say hey I'd
like to get to know you a little bit
better and spend a little more time with
you
leaning on the awkwardness collect good
people that's number one two is is
change your environment to be around the
people even if you can't meet them so
watching this video is a great example
watch this video did you wake up this
morning and you're like yeah my gosh so
amazing let's go Crush today
[Laughter]
probably not right I didn't if you if if
you did then I am super jealous of you
you probably woke up when you're tired
and you're looking at your phone and
what's on my calendar for today and
immediately some of the limiting beliefs
and thoughts and attitudes uh popped in
your head and so
if you can't be around the people every
day you know collect good people if you
can't be around them every day then
you can be around them virtually
through videos through YouTube through
books through uh social media follow the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and make you want to go off and
Conquer your goals most of the time when
people are spending time on social media
YouTube Instagram Etc
how much of that time is spent actually
learning and being inspired versus
wasting time
how many times have you opened your
phone went to a social media app and all
of a sudden 40 minutes went by you
didn't even notice because you're just
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
right has that happened
that's that's that's not what you want
to do
don't lean in on that right
audit right now audit who you are
subscribed to on YouTube and who you're
following on Instagram and ask yourself
do these people make me feel better
about myself or not
do I leave feeling more inspired than
when I came in and if no then unfollow
those people and good news is lots of
amazing people not just me there's tons
of amazing people who are making amazing
content
and whatever you want to learn whatever
you want to get more into
when you can surround yourself even in a
social media environment if you wanted
to work out more if you followed a whole
bunch of Fitness people people who are
working out constantly people who are
not you're making excuses for why they
can't get to the gym today if you
followed all those people it's now in
your environment you'll start to see it
more often it'll become it'll become
that daily reminder for you and you're
more likely to go to the gym and work
out so whatever you want to be whoever
you want to be whatever your goals are
choose to follow the people who are
achieving those goals who are living
that because it's not your identity yet
and for them it is and the more you're
around that they will suck you in to be
like them so choose very carefully what
you want to get sucked into right it can
also lead down a really negative dark
path right whoever's more confident in
their beliefs wins if you're around
people who are strongly believing in
something that is that is bad or evil or
you know against your core values you
know you could be sucked down a really
dark negative hole as well so Step One
is collect good people step two is to be
around them be around in social media
with intention the people who make you
feel better about yourself and and go
achieve your goals and then step three
is to join some kind of community join
some kind of group uh who are focused in
on on what you're trying to do so if you
wanna
if you want to get into fitness then you
you can hire a coach to help your
fitness trainer or join a gym or join
some kind of collective where you feel
like you don't have to do this by
yourself why movement makers is so
special is because if you want to be a
thought leader where do you go where do
you go to hang out with other thought
leaders
right nowhere do you know anybody who's
a thought leader is trying to make great
content and share it and have a message
to give to the world you know who who
else that you know in your life talks
like that probably not right so being
around that and and whatever it is that
you want to learn you want to be better
at chess then join a chess club and hire
a chess coach be around the people
be around the people join some kind of
community so you don't have to do this
all alone one of the things that I
struggled the most with is feeling like
I have to come up with all the ideas
myself carrying everything on my back
and what I realized
very later in my entrepreneurial Journey
right I mean I'm I'm
what I'm 40 how old am I now 40 I'm
almost 42 when I'm filming this video my
first Real Business and Entrepreneurship
when I was 19 so it's been a while you
know 20 plus years of being an
entrepreneur
uh not including like garage sales and
that kind of stuff and one of the
hardest things for me was just not
trying to have to do everything myself
not putting all the pressure on myself
to have to do everything everything
everything all by myself
I like to say movement makers that one
plus one equals four thousand you know
like you come in
and not just movement makers but any
anytime you do this any any club you
join or group you join especially if
you're a giver givers have a hard time
asking but when you're with other givers
they want to pour into you they want to
give to you they want to see you win as
well so you come in hoping to get
something and then when you get that
plus you can contribute to other people
and what they're doing and see that
you're showing up for them also allows
them to go off and accomplish their
goals
it's just such a great cycle
and it's such a weight lifted to know
that you don't have to do everything all
by yourself
so you could be willing to change you
could have these great Ambitions and
great ideas of who you could be and who
you want to be and the impact that you
want to have
but it's not going to happen until you
realize that you can't do this alone
stop trying to do this alone stop trying
to do everything yourself
you can change people will support you
but it's on you to collect good people
to audit who you follow on social media
and to join a group of people who are
like-minded
if you want to make one single change
this year
that will have a tremendous impact on
the growth of you actually accomplishing
your goals
side to not do this alone anymore think
big act small think big have a big goal
Big Dreams big desires big mission big
big Vision you're going to change the
world think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us
and nobody's seen us I just finished
this seven day challenge uh and built to
serve helping people become thought
leaders and people are afraid of people
watching their content and what their
what those people are going to say and
they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there anyone
that why you're not making is there any
wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look and your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not gonna be very
good probably
but that's okay doesn't mean you suck as
a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and you don't meet those
expectations and this Gap this is the
gap that prevents you from taking
further action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you
recorded a video watched it back were
completely embarrassed by yourself and
then never posted it and never launch
your channel there's been people who
I've done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent a decent
interview
but the insecurities and the fears and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect a suck at the beginning
just expect to suck expect it to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
can learn it of course you can learn it
you can pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the training education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's he's an
amazing human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of
asking people to be on the show and him
being the interview were he was fine
being an interviewee when people were
asking him questions but he didn't want
to be the interviewer and was afraid to
ask people questions and so we had a
discussion and we came up with a concept
where it was
um his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with the concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation he had a
guest come on and he was doing an
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expect it to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better and a little bit better and when
you look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days
100 days you'll come back and say holy
cow I'm really getting better why
because you developed a skill you were
you were still the same awesome human
now you're developing the skills to
actually get better at the thing that
you want to do makes all the difference
the only thing you're missing is
momentum so just repeat yourself repeat
to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
all you're missing is momentum
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that helped me that that that
gives me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the virus solo that there is no
bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it is a good idea trust
that that is the right idea for you that
you should do it that you should take
action on it and that it's going to
serve if you're in a positive mindset
right if you're if you're in a negative
mindset then then it's good to sleep on
your ideas right if you're in a jealous
mindset or hateful mindset or rageful
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are probably not the right ideas for you
but if you're in a powering empowering
inspiring positive optimistic mindset
then the ideas that come to you are the
right ones for you and just trust that
those are the right ideas and do
something on it and shortcut your brain
because as soon as your brain takes over
it's gonna be like oh okay but you don't
know how to do this and that and then
here's another problem and more
restrictions and you you know okay so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today don't make it some
big giant thing that now you need a
million dollars in venture capital and a
huge team to accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
let's go
her environment is keep keeping you
where you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them all
of them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years have said Evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people want it as
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with
it's important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
that the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker then the
fastest way to do it is to change your
environment so that's you I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is cut
out negativity just cut out the people
who don't serve you sometimes those are
friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the firewalk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed the skin so that I can be
reborn like does this new skin none of
you that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should
a less drastic version of that is just
don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
see I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become a
part of a co-working place can you be
around people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems or
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now
people they have problems you have
problems most people choose
entertainment as a way to forget about
their problems instead of Education as a
way to make their problems better do you
want to shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or do you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then Sun I like getting
Sun uh going outside being in nature
just having sun on my face not just
being stuck inside all day especially in
the morning makes a big difference my
third s is sore so I want to do
something makes me feel bold and come
alive and for me where I love my phone
here but for me I share a message I want
to share a message you want to feel like
the work that I do has meaning and
importance so I think about somebody
that I helped yesterday and then I share
a message on Instagram and Snapchat and
put it up that helps me soar what do you
need for yourself then I sweat so I'll
do a quick workout and then I do
something to scare myself right now it's
doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like oh and
I do difficult things that's my morning
routine right
I called the five five and a half s rule
because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to met
pray maybe you need to pet your cat
what is the thing that you need to do to
make you feel bold and alive and and
then schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself the main
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
focus on one idea and make it work focus
on one business model focus on one
Revenue stream focus on one social media
Network and make it work so many times
we're focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12 mostly
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the
answers don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much better it doesn't mean
that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and we don't
want to just do one thing we also feel
like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether to social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself so that I can quit my job if you
have one so that I can bring income in
for myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I can pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back on my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money that then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone help me with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have uh family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big gold and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so that I can start making money and
start building momentum one last quick
example I look at a lot of thought
leaders a lot of people have a message a
lot of people want to be speakers and
authors and coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
even selling courses your own materials
and training and Etc and coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
should be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business full
time
where everything else takes a lot more
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet people you don't have a brand yet so
could it work absolutely will it pay you
more than coaching yes absolutely most
likely it's way more easy to leverage
that than coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers
at the very beginning I'm much I'm a
much bigger fan of selling a service
than a product because it gets you
closer to your customers you get to know
their problems you know their issues you
know what exactly they're struggling
with and you can help them solve it
which allows you to create a better book
a better course a better product because
you've worked with enough people through
the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
right how much time has gone into your
course it's like we start and stop and
start and stop because we're tackling so
many different things because you want
to do it all and you want to have income
streams coming in like crazy and there's
nothing wrong with that it's amazing but
there's a sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
we just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus my key to being productive is
doing different things on different days
different activities different energy
states on different days if you feel
like you're getting to the end of the
day or getting to the end of the week
and you're working like crazy like
you're working you you were not sucking
off you're working like crazy and yet
nothing seemed to happen have you gotten
there it's like I did so much work this
week and yet I've moved very little
towards actually accomplishing my goals
if that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what I do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days I'll
break down for you what I do every day
of the week
Monday is my mentoring day Mondays are
the days where I spend mentoring my team
and we've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people who've
invested into as well in their companies
and Monday I just spend the whole day
talking to them all I have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
Tuesday is YouTube day so today I'm
filming on a Tuesday I don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a Tuesday for me filming all I have
to worry about on a Tuesday is making
YouTube content and why it's so
productive these days is because it
takes a while to make the first video it
takes a while to do the first call takes
a while to get momentum going but once
you get the momentum going
it's easier to stay in the momentum than
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's YouTube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like I
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right Vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
it takes it takes a while to get the
Mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video I could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
intermediate intermediate I want to say
sequential that's not a word succession
succession intermediate succession
whatever
after I can make three or four more
videos right after while I'm in that
same Vibe so same thing for you whatever
Vibe you're feeling if you can stay in
that energy Zone instead of switching if
I did YouTube video then write in a book
then doing a phone call that meant for
my team then you're just bouncing around
too much and there's high high high
energy switching costs that then keep
you unproductive then this is I mean a
huge unlock because when you can figure
out how to chunk your time like this
brain fog goes away productivity
dramatically increases you suddenly have
a lot more free time as well to do
whatever you want to do Nina is back
she's in the house we are at Nina's
acupuncture let me put my seatbelt on as
we well as we get ready to go
so Tuesday's YouTube day and I spend the
whole day making videos Wednesday's
project day and on Project day I focus
on whatever projects I want to work on
and it's
I wake up in the morning I look at what
do I want to work on today and it's a
it's a lot more of a creative day
Tuesdays and Thursdays are very intense
productive days Wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what I had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive so judge
myself harshly when I was working on a
new project and it would take me a long
time and I felt like I got nothing done
that's okay creativity is not meant to
be efficient
so you won't be efficient on your
creative days on your creative tasks it
won't be efficient for you but that's
okay and I think you need to have
creative time built into your calendar
because if you're only doing things that
are productive you're going to burn out
you're gonna hate your life and you're
going to feel Limited you ever get bored
of your own business you get bored of
the things you're doing well there's not
enough creative time planned into your
week when do you get time to work on new
fun things that maybe pay off maybe
don't pay off when you have time to work
on that well you don't okay so that's
when people have midlife crisis or burn
out or want to throw it all away or quit
or stop doing this thing and so I think
you have to have some highly productive
days where you're really working on
achieving the goals that you know I have
to get these things done and then you
have to have some creative days where
you get to focus on whatever projects
you want that you're not judging
yourself harshly for being you know not
very efficient creativity is messy it's
designed to be that way and you need to
have some creative days in your calendar
or you will get tired of your business
and hate your life so that's Wednesday
Wednesday's creative Day project day
Thursday is public facing day and
Thursdays
I'm usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and I'm
I'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but I am and
it takes me a while to to get into the
zone of being around other people
[Laughter]
so on Thursdays I start with my family
and Movie Makers are my community of
thought leaders are trying to build
their business and get their message to
the world and Brent Linux is my
community of people on YouTube who want
to build their YouTube channel up
specifically and want the advice to to
grow and create and so I start my
Thursdays with them because it's it's
family it's safe it's friendly it's warm
and it makes me feel like what I do
matters and is important and then the
rest of Thursday is interviews and
podcasts and in Zoom calls and just all
day spreading the message
spreading the message you know we got we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because I just came from movement makers
or brand Linux
so I'm already in the in the zone of
sharing and creating and impacting and
seeing smiles and so I carry that energy
into my next interview on my next
podcast and the next thing that I'm
doing so if I'm booking to be on other
people's shows even if I'm booking for
my own show Thursdays it's always on a
Thursday it's always on a Thursday it's
always on a Thursday and I have five
minute breaks in between so it's usually
25 minutes or 55 minutes and then five
minute break and then on to the next one
on to the next one and so it's really
easy and all of a sudden it's seven
o'clock and
what happened to today I don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and it's
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
YouTube video or then go and wrap my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a Wednesday
it took me an hour just to get into
remembering what I did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where I left off last time
uh since there's a public-facing day
Friday is CEO day so that's what do we
need to do to grow my business you know
what what are the big projects instead
of working in my business work on the
business so Wednesday's work in the
business on Creative projects Friday is
if I'm going to be the CEO of my
business what does that look like what
do I need to be doing because if you're
an entrepreneur you're you're the CEO
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show and we have to
do a lot of things to drive the business
forward we have to be in our business we
don't have a giant team yet even at 37
people I do a lot of work in the
business as opposed to only just being
the CEO and just managing and
truthfully I like being in the business
I like like making videos like this is
not CEO time this is me being in the
business but I like it you know I think
I think people who often just be the CEO
if you're entrepreneurial and there's no
projects you're working on uh you you
grow distant from the business you don't
enjoy it so we all need time in our
calendar every week to focus on being
the CEO and now I spend all my Fridays
doing it at the beginning I just started
with two hours so two hours in my
calendar okay this is my CEO time and I
blocked it off and I made it important
and when I started doing that I started
seeing more results in my company
Saturday we applied to the weekends too
Saturday is fun day so Saturday spending
time with Nia doing whatever you know
going it's starting to get warm here in
Canada you can you can see you know the
grass finally green so if we're going
for a hike or trying out a restaurant or
going to uh street festival or just
something fun Sunday is family at midday
so all of the stuff that we have to do
to manage the family you know go grocery
shopping fold laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
Sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary Monday is mentoring
day Tuesday is YouTube day Wednesday's
project day Thursday is public facing
day Friday CEO day Saturday fun day and
Sunday is family admin day and that fits
my life
you know that's a calendar for my life
it won't photocopy perfectly over to
yours but the key is to chunk your time
and think about what is a balanced life
look like for me so that I'm happy I'm
creative I'm productive I'm moving
closer to becoming the person that I
want to be and if you can't control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh I can't I can't completely control my
day I can't have a YouTube day okay
don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through Instagram posts or
YouTube videos mindlessly that that
you're you're there with intention and
you're gonna you have so many you have a
certain amount of controllable hours I
think part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the Allure being
an entrepreneur is that freedom but if
you're not completely there yet you
still have controllable hours when you
get home from work to the time you go to
bed when you wake up to the time you go
to work and then on weekends you have
controllable hours
be more intentional with them
and decide what is the life that you
want to live that'll come down to then
the habits that you're executing on
daily which comes down to your calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
Zone instead of switching between a
mainly different tasks every day it
allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier and allows you
to get a lot closer to your goals this
is where intentional learning really
makes a difference
I can't tell you the number of events
that I've done
[Music]
whether it's virtual or in person where
there's always q a at some point
so if you're going to an event
where you're signing up for for a zoom
call and the person who you want to
learn from is on that call what most
people do is they become passive
listeners
you're passively taking out your notepad
and you're taking notes you got your
phone and you're like taking notes on it
and like oh that's a good Insight that's
a good Insight but it's passive because
you are not
going in to the event with an outcome
your goal should be if you want to make
learning active if you want to actually
get the most from the experience and be
able to make the contacts and get your
questions answered you have to know what
the question is going to be
that you're going to ask right so here's
what you should do
first off whoever Your Heroes mentors
guides are
you want to follow them on all the
platforms so they can go live I just
before this I was live on Instagram
and we had a whole bunch of people
asking questions
follow if you want to talk to me follow
me on Instagram
join my Discord Evan carmichael.biz get
in there we're having great
conversations but the people who are
your Heroes follow them on the platforms
where they might go live look at where
they might be speaking at an upcoming
event
and then when you go and attend that
event have a plan for your learning so
that it's not just passively going
through the exercise and activities that
they gave you that's all a bonus
if you're going to go to some conference
and there's an activity sheet or
workbook to go through great that's all
a bonus you need to know going in
what do I want to learn if I got a
chance to ask this person one question
what would that question be
what's the outcome that I want from this
most people don't do that
and you get caught up in the hype and
the energy and the motivation of ah so
amazing
but then you still didn't get the answer
that you could have had if you're just
more intentional
so you show up and then when they do the
questions like okay we're going to q a
boom you're the first one there
you're the first one there you're not
you're not you might be nervous your
heart might be pounding out of your
chest like crazy but you're the first
one there
you're standing by the microphone you're
ready to go you got your hand up before
they even go to q a in the zoom chat
right like you are ready to go with your
question the one that you want and
answer to
and then you're gonna ask the person hey
here's what I'm struggling with here's
what I'm working on
tell me why I suck
and then you get the feedback
if you apply that strategy
and go after the top five to ten people
in your industry in your Niche who are
doing the thing you can get access to
them
and if you intentionally show up with
that one question that you want an
answer to
and then you end it with tell me why I
suck
you'll get their brutal honest feedback
and get the advice you actually need to
grow great ideas flow through you teach
yourself train yourself that great ideas
are flowing through you that the idea
that you just came up with that you've
been thinking of that doesn't make any
sense is great is amazing and is right
for you because
quite often the ideas that come to you
don't make sense
are not practical someone like you
shouldn't do it
and whenever you're heading your heart
are misaligned
whenever your heart wants to do
something but your head tells you that
you can't do it
if you listen to your head you'll stay
small if you listen to the Practical
reasons why you can't do it then guess
what you won't do it you'll stay stuck
you'll stay small you'll stay crushed
for life knowing that you're capable of
more but never going after it so trust
that great things flow through you trust
that this thing that just came into your
mind if you're feeling bold ambitious
confidence in service that it's the
right thing for you and you need to go
and Chase it down the secret to getting
everything that you want out of life is
to think big and act small think big
have a huge Dream create a vision for
yourself that excites you that you want
to make happen and then act small don't
let the big dream be so big that it
becomes so scary and you never start
find the smallest possible way to just
get started think big act small
otherwise your dreams will stay exactly
that I recently had a guy pop into my
Instagram live who was a fitness Coach
and he's building some success up and
doing one-on-one Training Fitness and
helping people get results and he said
Evan how do I go bigger how do I build
my brand how do I get people to know me
outside of just my my pocket my
community
I said well you have to create content
you got to be a thought leader you got
to be an expert I got to see you doing
what you're doing how often are you
making videos
I said well I don't know making them
once a week okay great dude
how often do you go to the gym how often
do you work out how often do you care
about your nutrition
settle every day like you have to take
this same approach to your business to
making content to being a thought leader
said are you in shape and at the time
he's he's shirtless and then he said
yeah I'm in shape and he he pans down
and you see his abs and then back to his
face and got the smile on his face like
I love it man
you've put that into your daily routine
you're working out and eating right as
part of your daily routine he said yeah
but it's so hard to to go off and make
videos every day
what are your client
your client and eating properly that
it's so hard dude it's the same excuses
you've already figured this out in one
area of your life the problem is you're
not being consistent in the other areas
that if you want to blow up and be a
thought leader and get a lot of traction
attention and Views you need to get good
at the thing you don't become great at
anything doing it once a week
if you believe that you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something Michael
Jordan wasn't practicing basketball once
a week you just will never get great at
it you have all of this untap potential
all of this ability to go off and make a
huge impact but we never see it because
you're doing it once a week you just
will never get good at it you'll never
get good enough at the thing if you're
only doing it once a week so he says
what do I do great you put into your
routine
you already know how to do this you just
have done it for something else all of
you you've already been consistent on
something
now make this next business goal part of
your daily routine it's thinking big and
acting small most people think they can
have this big vision of where they could
go it's amazing I Believe in Your Vision
I love you I want to see you go off and
Crush that huge glow I think you can do
it
but then show me your calendar where you
take any action
because most people are spending too
much time just thinking thinking
thinking planning planning planning you
got to actually get going and doing it
daily consistent small action one video
from my friend who's running his gym now
one video is not going to do anything
one video one small Act is not going to
do anything it's the accumulation of the
daily videos that are coming out the
daily content the daily improvements
that's where you start to build momentum
the biggest thing that's missing for
most of your ideas is momentum because
you're thinking big but you're not
acting small I was in New Mexico
and I was doing uh on Super Bowl Sunday
my workshop and it was the smallest
group on our tour and we're talking
about morning routines and there was a
woman there and I asked her what what's
the most important part of your morning
routine
she said prayer I said so you pray how
often do you pray every day every day
every day you praise your praise perfect
how often do you feel
the prayer how often do you feel the
connection and how often are you just
saying the words
she said like half the time
great
other people might look to her and say
well look you do it every day even for
herself she might look in herself and
say great I did it every day as
Achievers we like to check the box right
you like to check the box I did it I did
it I did it I did it I did it I prayed I
watched the video I read the book I
brushed my teeth I whatever you have
your checklist and you did it right and
you feel great that you did it but if
you don't get the feeling
of courageousness and you just check the
box it doesn't count
so watching a video might be part of
your morning routine
great I I'm you know if it's mine I'm
honored to be a part of your journey if
it's somebody else is amazing do that
too
but if you know that watching a video is
the thing that helps make you feel alive
bold confident
you know that there are some days that
watching a video actually makes you feel
that way and other days where it doesn't
and you know that watching the same
video over and over and over and over
every day will lose its impact super
quick right day one you're motivated day
two already you've lost like 80 of the
motivation that you got from day one day
three it's basically over you run it for
a month forget it like you've already
memorized the words that the words don't
mean anything to you anymore
so you have to have some variety
and if you're watching a video while
you're doing something else
this is the achiever's curse you're
watching the video while you're brushing
your teeth while you're taking the dogs
out while you're cleaning the sink while
you're making the bed you're distracted
you're doing something else you're
trying to multitask right here's what
happened to the achievers you still get
to check the box to say that you watch
the video
but because you weren't present for the
video guess what happens there was no
retention there was no feeling you don't
feel ready to take on the day you don't
feel the boldness to courageousness and
therefore you don't go and have a great
day even though you checked off
everything on your morning routine
that's what makes a difference
so if you get to the end of your morning
routine and you don't feel bold powerful
courageous ready to go for the day
there's one of two things that you have
to do one is you audit your morning
routine you say What's missing
you know like does this still work for
you anymore what's missing do I need to
add something in do I need to add an
espresso video in during the morning do
I need to add reading do I need to add
working out do I need to add writing my
goals down like what do you need to do
to add and tweak and experiment and see
if it makes you feel better or two
maybe you just need to do the routine
again but with more intention maybe you
did the whole routine while you were
distracted
maybe you did the whole routine while
you're thinking something else
so you don't get the feeling there's
nothing wrong with the routine the
routine is great
routine is perfect for you
so if you don't show up with intention
if you don't show up and be focused on
it
you're not going to get the feeling
you could sit there and be in the chair
and think about going to classes going
to school you could sit there be in the
chair doesn't mean that you're going to
learn
you can sit there and watch your video
but if you're brushing your teeth and
doing eight other things
you're not going to get the feeling
this is the loving push forward that I
hope you accept
because everybody else is going to look
at you and see how much you're doing and
how perfect you are and how much
momentum you have and how many things
you're doing and they look up to you in
awe and you're an inspiration to them
and you should be because you are doing
amazing things
and at the same time you know it's
nothing compared to what you could do
but the difference between where you are
right now where you want to go is
actually not that big
the difference is just minor tweaks
between where you are right now where
you want to go for most of you it's just
minor tweaks
this is one of those minor tweaks
that if you could just stay consistent
on having a morning routine
and then inside of that consistency
doing the thing that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable alive ready to
start the day not expecting to be
amazing when you wake up but then doing
the thing that brings that out of you
every single day your life will change
what is the light that you want what are
the goals that you have for yourself
where do you want to be in your health
and your relationships and your business
your finances what do you actually want
out of life not what somebody else's
perfect life looks like right you go on
Instagram and you see people living on
the beach and and rolling around in
money like that maybe that's what you
want but maybe it's not what you want
and we get pulled into all these
different directions because we don't
have Clarity over what we actually want
so what do you actually want what do you
want out of life where do you want your
business to be what kind of company do
you want to run what are the what are
the ethics and morals that your company
is based off of who do you want to serve
and how do you want to help them how do
you want to show up in your relationship
who are you looking for in your partner
if you already have a partner you know
how do you want to show up better for
that time all of the things that matter
to you to get as clear as possible so
that when you see somebody else is doing
something else and they're happy great
you don't have to go do it because
you're happy chasing down your goals
part of the challenge is we see other
people who are happy
and often it's not even real happiness
it's just you know fake happiness for
the camera but you see somebody who
looks happy you know that you're not
happy and you think well maybe if I did
that then I'll be happy you know maybe
if I go write a poem like they did I'll
be happy and then you start to write a
poem because I hate writing poems right
so it's getting clear over what do you
actually want in your life who's the
person that you want to be
in any again from your finances to your
your business to the relationships to
your uh to health to different areas of
your life get as clear as you can on the
things that you want out of your life
the biggest risk is not taking a risk at
all
I love it so many people are so afraid
to follow their dreams to have this big
idea that they have that they want to go
off and accomplish we have this big
vision for ourselves and we're so afraid
of making the wrong decision that we do
nothing
that you see this big goal and you have
three four or five potential paths and
you have limited resources limited time
limited money limited abilities and you
want to say I need to make the perfect
decision because if I make the wrong one
it all falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all that's when you see somebody
else making tons of money off your ideas
that's when you fast forward 10 years
and you still haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that you had
and are crushing it and so the way to
get over it is to recognize that as soon
as you get an idea you need to find some
small way to test it and that you don't
have all the answers and that's okay and
that you're going to figure it out along
the way
don't be
naive like I was to think that you can
create a business plan and it's going to
be the perfect business plan you're
going to have all the answers figured
out and then you're just going to
execute that business plan because as
soon as you finish writing your business
plan and you get out into the world and
you start testing your assumptions
you'll find out that you made a lot of
mistakes that a lot of what you thought
would happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with a perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out and start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
I spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when I
got out to Market I realized a lot of
what I thought was going to happen a lot
of what I thought with the reactions
would be is now it actually happened
and that set me behind
and so being attached to that perfect
idea understand that that doesn't exist
there is no perfect plan there is no
perfect idea as soon as you get
something in your head as soon as you
get an idea for something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it
find some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even enjoy this
a lot of times these big goals that we
have for ourselves when you get into it
you want to be a YouTuber great you
start making videos you're like yeah I
don't really like that go figure that
out as soon as possible people wait
years before they go out and try their
first attempt at it and then they
realize you know what that wasn't for me
and so I strongly encourage you to one
as soon as you get an idea for something
something you want to test out something
that you think might work find some
immediate way to test it on a small
scale don't take a big risk don't go
mortgage your house don't go take out a
giant loan I hate spending money till
I'm making money find some small way to
get started what's the most important
part of my morning routine it's
remembering the intention how do I want
today to go not just having a list of
to-do's but actually writing down how
you want to feel and that message to
yourself they'll give you the extra push
that you need to move it forward come up
with your intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
a first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what I used to do before writing it down
I just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because I'd often
forget what am I doing today I don't
know I just woke up I'm tired I look at
my calendar and then with each one I
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it how do I want to show up
for this person if I'm making YouTube
videos how do I want to show up on
camera how do I want to show up for my
audience how do I want to show up for
you I would just mentally think about
that as I go through the day and I
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how I want to feel that
the intention going through each
individual item on my calendar what I
love about this
is I find that I'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning I just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully I served I
helped it's often after I answer some
questions on Instagram so I'm in the
service heart and mindset and I think
about how do I want to show up tomorrow
if you find that you have more energy at
night or more clarity or more boldness
at night then then do that think about
how do you want to show up tomorrow what
are your tasks write them down and with
each one just write down what the
intention is how do you want to show up
as a human for each one so not just a
list of to-do's but how you want to feel
going into each one
look is there even as an example every
day at 2 30 I spend time with Nina
okay
every day 2 30. take a break from
whatever I'm doing spend time with
Nathan we usually go outside for the
walk with the dogs uh if it's raining
we'll stay inside and do something
together just a quick break in the
middle of the day to spend time together
and that's in my calendar and on my
calendar it says 2 30
half an hour break with Nina
but I wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with Nina I wrote
down have fun and make her feel loved
I wrote something else down yesterday
but that's my that's my intention for
today have fun and make her feel loved
so last night I wrote that down I'm
looking at Nina she's lying in bed she's
you know about to fall asleep I don't
think how do I want to show up for her
tomorrow for our break
have fun
I make her feel loved
so I look at that again this morning
and I look at it again right now
and then here's what's gonna happen at 2
30. 2 30 I'm gonna be done filming my
videos I'm gonna look at my calendar
look at my sheet here let's say 2 30
time with Nina have fun make her feel
loved just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
I'm gonna show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something I'm going to
show up slightly different because I
reminded myself that it's not just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved and so if you do
that for all of the items on your
calendar
for every meeting that you've got for
every quiet time that you've got every
creative moment that you've got how do
you want to show up if you can write it
down I love the night before and then
under each one how do you want to show
up that Prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self figure out what your trigger
words are what are your trigger words
what are the things that you say to
yourself that keep you small that keep
you scared that keep you safe to keep
you from living your dreams what are the
trigger words that you use so for me
it's scary difficult and hard whenever I
say scary difficult to hard those are
the things that have become my trigger
words and now I have to go do the things
because I said them because I wrote them
I texted them I sent them I thought them
right when you when you figure out what
your trigger words are then
whenever you say them it's an indication
of here I am again playing small here I
am again telling myself that I can't do
it here I am again accepting these
reasons that I no longer want to accept
being afraid is a classic one for a lot
of people well I didn't do it because I
was afraid and we've accepted you've
accepted the fact that you're afraid as
being a good enough reason for you not
to do the thing that you want to do
and I would like to challenge that and
say that's no longer good enough reason
nope not anymore not for you not for
what you're capable of not for where you
want to go and not for the impact that
you can have nope not a good enough
reason anymore let's go
so if you just sit and think about what
are the trigger words that you say what
are the what's the language that you use
that keeps you small scared protected
that you no longer want to be good
enough reasons that you want to be free
of rid of and that we're taking from our
subconscious mind automatic patterns
into our conscience and to know I am
going to make a change in my life I no
longer want to be this person I need to
evolve and grow and get better and be
better because I'm capable right you so
when you figure out your your trigger
words and and try to come up with them
but it's a good exercise to do right now
what are the words that you tell
yourself
when you're scared when you're afraid
when you've got big ideas and you talk
yourself down from what are the what's
the language you use you can start by
just taking on mind scary difficult hard
or you can come up with your own but
they did become anytime you see yourself
using that language
it triggers you to then make a shift to
say oh okay because I said that because
I said scary difficult or hard now I'm
going to do it just because because I'm
the kind of person who does scary who
does difficult who loves hard
and when you can take those words that
have previously disempowered you and
flipped them so that they be they become
empowered for you that's how you start
to shift your identity forward at the
end of the day the thing that matters is
is how you feel about yourself when you
buy yourself the the language you use to
talk about yourself the messaging you
have to yourself when you look at
yourself in the mirror when you're going
to sleep when there's nobody else around
you because when you can build that
self-belief when you can build that
self-love when you can build that
self-confidence that self-esteem
that becomes the rocket fuel for you to
build the great life for you your family
the people around you and create the
impact that you know you're capable of
having
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there you don't go to school to learn
you go to school to get a degree and
that degree hopefully helps you get a
job that you're looking for but you
don't go to school to learn there's just
so many more effective ways to learn
than to go to